字幕: Marina Samejima
校正: Shoko Takaki
ここに ８人の人がいます
ちょっと 考えてみてください
この中に「LGBT」といわれる
セクシャルマイノリティーの人達は
何人いると思いますか？
１人、３人、あと６人、８人
この４つの選択肢の中から一つ
手を挙げてもらってもいいでしょうか？
では いきますよ
この中にLGBTの人
１人だと思う人？
ゼロで
はい ありがとうございます
じゃあ ３人だと思う人？
はい 多いですね
ありがとうございます
では ６人だと思う人？
はい こっちも多いですね
じゃあ最後 ８人全員だと思う人？
はい ありがとうございます
正解を発表します
正解は ６人なんですね
では 誰がLGBTで 誰がLGBTではない人か
分かる人はいますか？
恐らく ほとんどの人が
分からないんじゃないかなという風に思います
これがLGBTの問題の本質なんですね
LGBTは「いない」のではなく
「見えていない」だけで
私達の身の回りの所に
例えば 家族だったり 友人だったり
職場だったり 学校だったり
あらゆる所に存在しています
では 質問続きですが
もう１つ質問させてください
この中にいるLGBTの人 それぞれ
どういったセクシュアリティ 「性のありかた」を
もっている人達でしょうか？
LGBTって言われているんだから
レズビアンやゲイ
バイセクシャル、トランスジェンダー
この４つのどれかなんじゃないの
という風に
思う人が多いと
思うんですけれども
ちょっと 説明をさせてください
おそらく 頭の中がすごく
混乱すると思うので
まずはちょっとサラーッと
聞き流してみてください
いきます
一番手前側の
帽子を被っている人は
身体の性が女性 そして心の性が男性の
トランスジェンダーですが
好きになる性が男性なので
トランスジェンダーで
ゲイを自認しています
そして その次の人は
好きになる性が男性 と 一部の女性
そして一部のトランスジェンダーも含むため
「ポリセクシャル」という
セクシャリティを自認しています
そして ３人目 着物を着た人は
「パンセクシャル」 日本語では
「全性愛」という風に言うんですけれども
好きになる性に性別は問わないという
セクシャリティです
そして４人目はLGBTではない人
そして真ん中向かって右側の人は
身体の性が男性ですが 心の性が
女性でもなければ男性でもない という
「エックスジェンダー」という
セクシャリティです
そして右から二番目の人は
LGBTではない人
そして最後 一番右側の人は
「アセクシャル」といって
好きになる性 そもそも恋愛感情を
抱かないというセクシャリティです
さあ どうでしょうか？
頭の中がすごく混乱したんじゃないかな
という風に思います
すっごい良い感じに
ポッカーンとなっていて
いいと思います
ありがとうございます
では この混乱ついでに
もう１つ最後に質問させてください
私のセクシャリティは何でしょうか？
もう 皆さんもう
なんか色んな情報があって
「もうお前何なんだ！？」 みたいな感じだと
思うんですけれども
私は 当てはめるとしたら
いわゆる「ゲイ」―
男性として男性が恋愛対象になるゲイに
当たるのかなという風に思っています
ここで 何を言いたかったかというと
「LGBT」という言葉にはもう限界が
あるんじゃないかな ということなんですね
「LGBT」という言葉は
すごく戦略的に
性的マジョリティにマイノリティを
認知してもらうために
使われてきました
まだまだ認知は完全とは
言えないと思いますが
近い将来 ここ日本でも
メディアがだんだんLGBTのことも
取り上げ始めているので
いつか ここ日本でも LGBTは
当たり前の存在になるんじゃないかな
という風に思っています
LGBTではない人が
LGBTを受け入れた社会
その先には
何が待っているのでしょうか？
これから 未来の話をしたい
という風に思っています
とはいえ とはいえ
「LGBTって初めて聞いた」 とか
「LGBTって見たことが無い」って言う人も
いるかもしれませんので
まずはちょっとだけ
LGBTのことを説明しながら
未来について話していきたいな
という風に思っています
「LGBT」とは
「レズビアン」 「ゲイ」 「バイセクシャル」
「トランスジェンダー」の
４つの頭文字からとった
セクシャルマイノリティの総称の１つです
レズビアンとゲイは
女性・男性の同性愛者
そしてバイセクシャルは 両性愛者
トランスジェンダーは
身体の性に対して
心の性やジェンダーの表現が
一致していない人 のことを指します
LGBTといって
４つの頭文字から取っていますが
先ほどの８人も含めて
他のセクシャリティも含んだ総称として
使われることが多いです
電通が2015年に出した調査では
日本の人口のうちLGBTは7.6%
13人に１人いる
という風に言われています
例えば 左利きの人口だったり
例えば AB型の人口より多いと
言われていたり
日本で多いとされる４つの名字
「佐藤さん」 「鈴木さん」
「高橋さん」 「田中さん」の
４つより多い という風に
言われているんですね
ちょっと聞いてみましょう
この中で 「佐藤さん」 「鈴木さん」
「高橋さん」 「田中さん」の人？
はい
ちょっと周りを皆さん
見渡していただけると分かるんですけれども
この人口のうちに これぐらい
で LGBTは
これぐらいか もうちょっと多い
という風に言われているんですね
どうですか？
多いと思いましたか？
ちょっと少ないと思いましたか？
この LGBT なんですけれども
まだまだ 日本を見てみると
LGBTということが
話題のネタに使われてしまって
いじめやハラスメントに
つながってしまったり
なかなかコミュニティに
属しづらかったりして
LGBTは カミングアウトしても
受け入れられないんじゃないか
という風に思い込んで
なかなか本当の自分のことを話せない
それに対して
LGBTではない人は
LGBTなんて見たことがない
どういう人達か分からないから
配慮のしようがない という―
この負のスパイラルみたいな感じが
続いてしまっているのかな
という風に思います
この負のスパイラルを
断ち切ることはできないのでしょうか
いえ 私はそうではない
という風に思っています
この負のスパイラルを
断ち切れる存在が
１つあります
それが 「ALLY」という存在です
ALLYとは 英語の alliance からきていて
支援者や同盟 味方 という意味を表す―
LGBTのことを良いと思っている―
主にストレートの人のことを指す言葉です
なぜALLYが増えると良いのかというと
例えば LGBTが
カミングアウトしやすくなったり
カミングアウトしていなくても
周りに味方がいる 理解してくれる人がいる
ということが分かるので
より安心して暮らすことができます
例えば 飲み会で ホモやオカマ
男女 というような
差別用語を使って
笑いが起きていた時に
ALLYがいて
その言葉って実は良くないんだよ
という風に言ってくれたら
もしかしたら
そこにいるかもしれないLGBTが
そのコミュニティで より安心して
生きることができるんですね
では ALLYになるためには
どうすればいいんでしょうか
実はALLYになるのって
すごく簡単なんです
まず１つ目に
LGBTについて知ること
そして２つ目に
自分はALLYである
ということを表明する
たったこれだけなんですね
ちょっと自分の話を
してみたいという風に思います
自分は・・・カミングアウト
自分がゲイであることを
カミングアウトし始めたのは
高校卒業してから
なんですけれども
初めて母親にカミングアウトした時に
母親から言われた言葉を
今でも覚えています
自分の名前は
松岡宗嗣（まつおかそうし）というので
「そうし」という風に
呼ばれているんですけれども
「宗嗣の人生なんだから
好きに生きなさい
宗嗣が病気になった時に
誰かが隣にいてくれる
ということが大事で―
それが一番 親としては心配だ」 と
「その隣にいるのが男でも女でも―
そんなものは何でもいい」
という風に言ってくれました
この言葉が すごく今の自分の
すごく自信に繋がっていて
こうして活動ができています
そんな私は当事者の立場から
こうしたALLYを増やすために
今 活動しています
例えば
LGBTについて伝える出張授業を
展開するNPOに所属していたり
昨年の12月には
ここ 明治大学に
まずはALLYを増やそうということで
MEIJI ALLY WEEK という
一週間のキャンペーンを企画しました
LGBTとALLY
この関係が上手くいけば
ここ日本でも
LGBTは当たり前の存在になるんじゃないかな
という風に思っています
前置きが長くなってしまいましたが
ここまでが LGBTについての話
では 未来はどうなっているのでしょうか？
もう一度 冒頭の写真を
見てみたいと思います
この中にLGBTは何人いますか？
誰がLGBTで
誰がLGBTではない人でしょうか？
加えて
ここにいる会場の方１人１人
あなたのセクシャリティは何ですか？
私は
私も含めて ここの８人も含めて
そしてこの会場の人 １人１人も含めて
全員が １人１人にセクシャリティって
もってるんじゃないかな という風に―
考えていて そして
そのセクシャリティやジェンダーというのは
グラデーションになっているんじゃないかな
という風に思っています
セクシャリティやジェンダーは
グラデーション
セクシャリティ、ジェンダーは
ジェンダーはグラデーション・・・
そう 私が考えた概念は
「ジェンダーグラデーション」 です
誰を好きになるか 好きにならないか
自分の性をどう思っているのか
例えば 「男らしさ」や「女らしさ」など
自分の性をどう表現するか
セクシャリティやジェンダーは
グラデーションになっていて
一人一人が多彩な性の
グラデーションの中の１つである
そして 誰もが自分らしさを表現できる
これを私は
ジェンダーグラデーション
という風に表現しました
ちょっと 言葉にすると
難しいかもしれませんね
なので私は この
MEIJI ALLY WEEK の中で
これをファッションショーで
提示してみました
それが こちらです
ジェンダーグラデーションを
表現するために
ファッションを１から制作して
これを表現しました
ちょっと１つ 紹介させてください
このファッションは
身体の性が女性
そして心の性が男性の
トランスジェンダーのための
マタニティウェアです
例えば トランスジェンダーの人の中でも
男性として生きていきたいけれども
子供は自分で産みたい という人もいたり
トランスジェンダーの中で
手術によって身体を変えたい人もいれば
そうじゃない人もいたり
本当にグラデーションに
なっているんですよね
ただ 思い返していただくと分かると
思うんですけれども
現在（いま）のマタニティウェア―
おそらく ほとんどのものが
女性用のものなんじゃないかな
と思います
そういったことで
このファッションを制作しました
また
ジェンダーグラデーションの世界では
ALLYの概念も
少し変わってくるんじゃないかな
という風に思っています
先ほど ALLYの説明の中では
alliance からきていて
支援者や同盟者、味方を表す
主にストレートの人
というような表現をしました
実は私は それだけではないんじゃないか
と思っています
例えば 私はゲイですけれども
例えば レズビアンや
他のセクシャリティの人達が
悩んでいたら
味方でありたいな という風に
思っていますし―
例えば ストレートの人が
男らしさや女らしさに「面倒くさいな」
という風に思っていたら
同じように
味方でありたいな
という風に思っています
このように
LGBTもALLYになれるんじゃないかな と
考えているんです
また
もしかしたらこのALLYという言葉―
LGBTだけの言葉じゃないかもしれない
という風に思っています
１人１人が持つあらゆる違いに対して
味方でありたい という風に思ったとき
私も含めて
そしてここの会場にいる人
１人１人全員含めて
誰もが誰かのALLYになれるんじゃないかな
という風に思っています
そんなALLYを増やすために
MEIJI ALLY WEEK では
もう１つイベントを実施しました
それがこちら
"Ally in White" = 白い服を着たALLY
という意味のイベントです
参加者の方には
白い服を着て集まってもらって
写真を撮って
そして 自分はALLYである
ALLYになりたい ということを
「#MEIJI ALLY WEEK」を付けて
SNSで拡散してもらう―
そういったイベントです
なぜ 白い服にしたかというと
光の三原色を集めると
白色になるんですよね
そこから分かるように
実は 白色の中には
色んな色が含まれているんです
そこから分かるように
誰もが ここから
自分の好きな色 ―
自分らしい色を誰もが表現できるように
という願いを込めて
私達は白い色を選択しました
もう一度 冒頭の写真を
振り返ってみましょう
もうお分かりですよね
全員が白い服を着ています
そして今日
私も白い服を着ています
誰もが誰かのALLYになれる―
そんなことを表現するために
白い服を着ました
もう一回
一番最初の質問をさせてください
この中に LGBTは何人いますか？
誰がLGBTで
誰がLGBTではない人でしょうか？
そしてこの中にいるLGBT
それぞれどういったセクシャリティ
性のあり方をもっている人達でしょうか？
そして 私のセクシャリティは何ですか？
そして最後に
ここにいる皆さん
あなたのセクシャリティは何ですか？
答えは―
１人１人が多彩な性の
グラデーションの中の１つで―
そして全員がALLYだと思います
ちょっと大ざっぱかもしれませんが
これが 私の考える
ジェンダーグラデーションの世界です
ALLYになることは
実はすっごく簡単です
自分はALLYであるということを
表明する
たった これだけなんですね
是非 皆さんも
ALLYになってみてください
ありがとうございました
（拍手）